BRETT HESTERBERG:
Good afternoon.
We're about one second past
noon, so good afternoon
everyone.
My name is Brett Hesterberg.
I'm the product
manager for Cloud SQL.
I'm joined today
by Stanley Feng.
Stanley is the technical lead
for our Cloud SQL performance
engineering team.
And we're talking today about
performance and availability
on Cloud SQL, specifically
on Cloud SQL's MySQL product.
So as part of the
talk today, we're
going to cover a little
bit on what Cloud SQL is.
We'll talk about how to scale
Cloud SQL infrastructure, how
to scale your database instance
up, and how to scale out.
And Stanley then will cover
balancing availability
and raw MySQL
performance, especially
in the context of MySQL's
semi-synchronous replication
technology.
From there, we'll get into
some InnoDB tuning settings
that we use on Cloud SQL.
I'll note there that
you're more than
welcome to snap
picture the slides,
and this video we posted online.
But Cloud SQL actually
posts our tuning parameters
on GitHub Gist, so we have
those all in one place for you.
So no need to try to write
down some of the settings
that Stanley mentions.
We'll give you the URL at
the end of the presentation.
The hope here is that
for those of you who
are Cloud SQL users
today, you learn something
about scaling Cloud SQL.
And for those of you who
are running MySQL yourself,
you at least can crib off of
our InnoDB tuning parameters,
as a way to get started more
rapidly with MySQL on GCB.
And then we'll get
into some next steps,
and kind of wrap up from there.
But first, I want to ask a few
questions to get to know you
a little bit.
By show of hands, how many
of you are developers?
We'll call that,
what, 2/3 of the room?
2/3 of the room?
How many of you are database
administrators, DBAs?
And maybe a quarter of the room.
How many of you
are reluctant DBAs?
A few more hands there.
OK.
And how many managers do
we have in the audience?
We've got a fair
percentage there.
OK, thanks for that.
A couple more questions for you.
How many of you use
MySQL frequently?
How many are you using
it almost day to day?
OK, much of the room.
How about PostgreSQL?
Oh, we've got a few hands there.
OK.
And how many of you are
current Cloud SQL users?
That's pretty good.
All right, thank you.
OK.
So format wise, we've got
mics at the front of the room.
Stanley and I are
going to leave time
at the end of the presentation
for your questions.
So if things are coming into
your mind as we go along,
please jot them
down, and make sure
that we get to ask them at
the end of the presentation.
We will also hang around
after the presentation
if you have
additional questions.
And we have members of the
Cloud SQL engineering team here,
the people who actually
built the product, who
will be able to answer
your questions as well.
So let's jump in.
Cloud SQL is a managed
database service.
Our goal is to take mundane
database administration tasks
and make them much easier.
Cloud SQL is not a DBA.
For developers, we hope that
Cloud SQL makes it easier
for you to focus a bit more on
development, and a little less
on database administration.
And for DBAs, we
hope you get to do
something more interesting than
install and patch databases.
I will note that historically,
Cloud SQL has offered MySQL.
And when I say we offer
MySQL, we don't just
offer a MySQL
compatibility layer,
we offer standard MySQL
standard binaries.
Which means with few exceptions,
if your application works
with MySQL, it will
work with Cloud SQL.
I'm very happy to note that
as of yesterday, Cloud SQL is
launching PostgreSQL support.
And again, this doesn't
mean a compatibility layer.
This means standard PostgreSQL
database on Cloud SQL.
So a couple of notes on that.
Because we did have
a fair number of you
in the audience who raised
your hands to my PostgreSQL
question, and I see a few
familiar faces out there
from the presentation
yesterday, PostgreSQL
is launching, as
of yesterday, when
I say launching I
truly mean launching.
If some of you pull up your
cloud console, some in the room
will see PostgreSQL right
now, while others will not.
As the day progresses, and
certainly into the weekend,
more and more of you will see
PostgreSQL in your console.
If you are familiar with our
CLI and our APIs, all of you
can create a PostgreSQL
instance right now.
So we hope you
get started there.
A few notes on PostgreSQL.
We support up to 32
core and 200 gig plus
instances on PostgreSQL.
The same goes for MySQL, our
large instance type, 32 cores
and 208 gigs of RAM.
We also offer inexpensive
development instances,
starting at a little
less than $10 again,
both for PostgreSQL
and for MySQL.
On the PostgreSQL side,
looking at connectivity,
PostgreSQL today--
Cloud SQL for PostgreSQL--
supports connectivity
from Compute Engine, from App
Engine flexible environment,
which just went GA
at this conference,
From Google Container
Engine, and generally
from any client with a
standard PostgreSQL connector.
Two caveats here.
One is that posts--
or Cloud SQL for
PostgreSQL product
does not yet
support connectivity
from App Engine
standard environment,
which our MySQL product does.
And generally, Cloud
SQL does not yet
connect with Cloud Functions,
although we're working on that.
Cloud Functions was announced
here at this event as well.
I've listed the
extension support
we've come out with on the
PostgreSQL product at beta.
Extensibility is likely one
of the most powerful features
that PostgreSQL offers.
We do offer the very
popular PostGIS extension,
which builds in very
powerful geospatial support
into PostgreSQL.
And you see some others here.
That said, you've
got us here, you've
got the Cloud SQL team here.
And we want your
feedback on extensions.
If you're using
PostgreSQL today,
you use an extension you don't
see on this slide, let us know.
We also have some
forums online where
you can get that kind
of information to us.
We're all ears when it
comes to extensions.
OK.
So let's get into Google's
database storage portfolio.
The database portfolio at
Google is broad and growing.
So I think one relevant question
is, where does Cloud SQL fit
into all of this?
If you start right
most on this slide,
BigQuery is our data
warehousing product.
We store objects in
Google Cloud Storage.
We have two non-relational
or NoSQL databases,
in Datastore and Bigtable.
And then you get to
the relational column,
where Cloud SQL and
Cloud Spanner lives.
If you haven't had a chance
to go to the Spanner talks,
I encourage you to watch the
YouTube recordings of those,
or just get to know
Spanner with some
of the online documentation.
It's a product we just
recently announced.
And left most on the slide
is our App Engine Memcache
product, which is our
in-memory database product.
So this kind of leads
to the question,
which is which of these
products do I pick?
You may have seen
this flow chart
before in other presentations.
It's just meant to,
at a high level,
kind of guide you to the
right Google database product.
In this session, we
are talking about
structured transactional
relational data that gets you
to the bottom left
of this slide, where
Cloud SQL and Spanner live
as our relational products.
And then let me just
ask, by a show of hands,
how many of you are
comfortable saying,
I know the difference between
Cloud SQL and Spanner?
So about a third of the room.
Just very quickly, and
there's much more depth
than I'm going to touch on here,
Cloud SQL is compatibility.
Again, we're not just
a compatibility layer
for MySQL and PostgreSQL.
We are offering standard MySQL
and PostgreSQL databases.
Cloud SQL, like many
relational database services,
is able to scale
out reads, and we'll
talk about this in
this presentation,
but we are not able to scale
out writes past a single node.
So one difference
between Cloud SQL,
from a performance
perspective, and Spanner,
is that Spanner does
horizontally scale writes.
And that's the horizontal
scalability question
you see in this flowchart.
The other note here is
around that compatibility.
So if you have a
MySQL application,
a PostgreSQL application,
with very few exceptions
it will work with Cloud SQL.
Spanner has its own
compatibility model,
which means if you're
coming with a MySQL
or PostgreSQL or an
Oracle app, you likely
need to take a look at
changes to that application
so that it works with Spanner.
Spanner comes with a myriad
of benefits in terms of scale
and global availability of data.
I encourage you to get
to know it a bit more.
But for the purposes
of this talk
today, we're going to be
focused squarely on Cloud SQL
here forward.
OK.
So I've talked about Cloud
SQL being a managed database
service, and I think
it's worthwhile to take
a look at what it takes
to run a database.
It's just a way to
illustrate differences
between self-managing
a database like MySQL,
and using something
like Cloud SQL.
And in the end, it all
comes down to trade offs.
I, obviously, have a bias as the
product manager for Cloud SQL.
I love managed database service.
But there are merits
to both self-managing
and managed database services.
So let's start
with the hardware.
Some of you are today
running on prem.
You are thinking about things
like power and cooling,
racking and stacking of servers,
maybe configuring servers
on some vendor's website.
Whether you are doing that or
you've offloaded some of that
to another group in your
company, a colo, a cloud
provider like Google, I
would encourage all of you
to still think about
server maintenance.
Here at Google, part of our
server maintenance strategy
is live migration.
You can read a number of blogs
that the Compute Engine team
has put out on live migration.
I think it's a really
cool feature with respect
to server maintenance.
And server maintenance should
be on all of our radar,
given that it has obvious
implications to our application
stack.
Cloud SQL, by the way, benefits
from live migration as well.
Let's take a look at the OS.
And this is where
we really start
to see a fork in the road
between self-managing MySQL,
for example, on Compute
Engine here in Google Cloud,
or using something
like Cloud SQL.
On Compute Engine, you
will be installing the OS
or picking an image
with an OS installed,
patching and
maintaining that OS.
On Cloud SQL, we
mask the OS from you.
You don't have access to the OS.
We take care of
the installation,
the patch is keeping it secure.
From a database perspective,
in a self-managed world,
obviously you're
installing MySQL.
You are patching it on some
regular interval, I hope.
And you're setting up backups.
Cloud SQL, again, does the
install, does the patching,
and makes backups automatic,
or and also gives you
APIs to call them on demand.
And then for advanced
features, when
you're looking at
high availability,
those self-managing
MySQL today know
that you're thinking about
things like replication,
you're looking at tooling to
discover, is my database--
my master database healthy?
Do I need to failover?
If I do, you're either using
alerts to manually failover,
having someone paged,
or you've written
scripts that load balance
and failover to another MySQL
instance.
Cloud SQL does this
on your behalf.
It's a check-box in Cloud SQL
to set up high availability.
We take care of the
replication they'll
be talking a fair
amount about today,
as well as all the
tooling to health
monitor and do your failover.
The other thing you get with
a managed database service
is that you get the
backing of Google's team.
When you're
self-managing, your team
is responsible for keeping
that database system up.
When you move to Cloud SQL,
you lean on Google's team
to do that for you.
Last note, in terms of
this stack, is scaling.
Self-managed world, you
are deciding when to scale,
and how to scale.
How do I scale up?
How do I scale out?
In Cloud SQL, we make
scaling easy for you.
But unlike other
database products
in the portfolio I
showed you earlier,
Cloud SQL does not auto scale.
So you, as an
administrator, still
need to decide it's
time for me to scale.
Cloud SQL makes scaling
up and out fairly easy,
but you are the one who
triggers that action.
And last, but not
least, is monitoring.
This is not only things
like application monitoring
with stacked driver
here in Google Cloud,
but also answering
questions like,
can I get slow query
logs sent to Pub/Sub?
Or to cloud logging for easy
consumption by third party
products, like
Splunk, for example.
Cloud SQL and
managed services do
a lot of that plumbing for you.
Whereas in the
self-managed world,
you're doing that
of your own accord.
The bottom line when I look at
self-managing versus managing
is it's a trade off.
You all are making trade offs
with your time day to day.
Certain parts of your technology
stack, you want to customize,
you want to spend
more time there.
And that means you're
willing to maintain it.
Other parts, you may say, I
don't want to maintain it,
and I'm willing to give up
some of that customization
to avoid the maintenance.
OK.
So looking at scaling
Cloud SQL at itself,
we're going to first
focus on infrastructure.
And then we're going to get into
some real details around MySQL.
Scaling up, I think
is pretty intuitive
when it comes to database.
We encourage it
because it works.
It works as high as you
can scale up, that is,
and it's relatively
straightforward.
In Cloud SQL and
generally in Google Cloud,
it's easy to add CPU cores
and memory to your instances.
When you add them
and you click Apply,
we do take a reboot in
Cloud SQL and on GCE,
as you scale up CPU and RAM.
I think those are pretty
intuitive scale up levers.
One less intuitive
way to scale up
is scaling up
storage performance.
In Google Cloud platform,
we scale storage performance
with capacity.
So as you add
capacity to PD-SSD,
you get more IOPS
and measurement
of storage performance.
Same goes with Cloud SQL.
You see some numbers here on
the right hand of the slide.
Also you see a screen
shot on the left hand
part of the slide.
In Cloud SQL, we show you
a performance calculator
so that as you adjust the size
of your instance number of CPU
cores, for example, and
the capacity of your,
in this case, persistent
disk SSD drive,
we show you what you
can expect in terms
of storage performance and
overall machine performance.
In the example I've shown here,
I selected a 32 core machine,
our largest instance
type in Cloud SQL,
and you can see it can deliver
me a maximum of 25,000 IOPS.
That limit has
actually been raised
as of this conference,
as Persistent Disk has
raised its limits.
But a maximum in this
example of 25,000 IOPS.
But given that
I've only selected
600 gigabytes for
my storage capacity,
I will only deliver 18,000 IOPS.
So one action I can take
now is increased capacity
of my storage to
max out those IOPS.
I'll note here that when
we increase capacity
of storage, and
thus performance,
this is an online operation.
You need not take
down your database.
In fact, Cloud SQL
has an auto storage
grow feature, if
you check that box,
will watch your
capacity for you.
When you need more capacity,
we'll grow your storage device,
and we do so online.
The database doesn't go down.
Scaling up, making sense?
Easy enough.
OK.
At some point, you say I'm
punishing my single MySQL
instance so much that I need to
consider moving some load off
of it.
As I mentioned at the
beginning, Cloud SQL
makes scaling out reads easy.
We allow you to very simply
create read replicas.
And just by show of hands here,
how many of you in the room
are familiar with differences
between Cloud SQL's
semi-synchronous replication and
its asynchronous replication?
So a number of you are
fairly comfortable with that.
Let me give you the
one minute overview.
semi-synchronous
replication, Cloud SQL
uses for availability.
You see in this chart, we see
three total database instances
here.
This is a very
common configuration.
I have my master
instance leftmost.
I have a failover
replica, the place
I will failover if some problem
happens to my master instance.
What I'm optimizing,
therefore, is data.
When I failover, I
want to be very sure
that the last transaction
my application sent
to the master that
was committed,
is indeed in the
failover replicas.
That when I failover,
I have my data intact.
To do that, MySQL incurs
performance overhead.
The master will wait
for the failover replica
not to commit the transaction,
but to acknowledge
that that transaction
is in its relay log.
So if you imagine the
transaction coming
from the application,
without a replica,
it goes from the application
to the master instance,
the master instance commits
it, tells the application I've
got it, and the
application is now
free to send
another transaction.
When we add this
failover replica,
the matter takes the
application's transaction,
it waits for the
failover replica
to say I've got it
in my relay log.
Once it does that and commits
the transaction locally,
it gets back to the application.
So you can see the performance
overhead that is incurred here.
The benefit, of course, is
you get data in two places.
In Cloud SQL, we always make
sure your failover replica
is in a separate
zone, effectively
a failure domain or you can
think of it as a separate data
center, so that if a problem
occurs in one data center zone
A, we can failover to zone B.
This differs from Cloud SQL's
asynchronous replication
in that asynchronous replication
does not require the master
to wait for the replica to
acknowledge the transaction.
So my application can
send a transaction,
the master says, I'm
going to commit it,
I'm going to make sure
that my replica is aware
that it needs to do
something, but I'm not
going to wait for that replica
to actually take action
before I get back
to the application.
In this way, you
incur less overhead
with an asynchronous replica.
So asynchronous replicas
Cloud SQL does not
use for failover because there
is a chance it does not have
the same dataset as the master.
We do use them for
read scale out.
And in this depiction,
what you're seeing here
is an application is able to
write to the master instance,
and read from any of the
replicas, and of course,
the master instance itself.
So from a scale-up
perspective, what
we've been able to accomplish
here in our application is
we've moved expensive reads.
For example, ad hoc
queries or reports
that get generated on Friday
afternoon, to a replica,
so that our master instance
can focus more of its cycles on
writes.
Make sense to everyone?
And we'll get deeper
as we go along.
So I mentioned a few times now,
Cloud SQL makes scaling easy,
but it doesn't auto scale.
You have to make a decision
as to when to scale.
And so that begs
this question, we
recommend strongly
you know your numbers.
When you look at the
Cloud SQL console,
you see a basic set of stats
that are available to you.
We're showing one of
those stats in this chart.
We also, as Cloud SQL, turn
on the InnoDB metrics table
that you can query for
really deep MySQL stats.
And we encourage you to refer
to both of these in addition
the Stackdriver, as you
make decisions about is it
time to scale up?
Or if I scaled up
as far as I can,
is it now time to
scale my reads out?
With that, we're going to
get into a bit of discussion
on the relationship between
availability and performance.
And especially how availability
and raw performance
are very much intertwined.
And I'll hand things
over to Stanley.
Thanks, Stanley.
STANLEY FENG: Thanks, Brett.
Can you guys hear me?
All right.
Cool.
So I can have two topics.
Today, one is about
availability and performance
as shown on this slide.
The other topic is about,
I can talk a little bit
about the InnoDB
[INAUDIBLE] tuning we have
done to make the Cloud SQL.
MySQL works best on
the GCE platform.
So let's start with this
availability and performance.
In this section, I'm going
to talk about how do we best
balance in between replication
lag and the raw performance.
So let's start with
a brief introduction
in the overview of the
Cloud SQL HA architecture.
So HA here stands for
high availability.
Brett already gave
us a brief overview
of what semi-synchronous
replication is.
So basically, yes,
our HA architecture
is currently viewed on top of
semi-synchronous replication
feature, which is built
in and available in MySQL.
And as you can see, on this
picture there is a master
and there's a slave.
And both are live and
hot online instances.
And then the master
supports reads and writes.
The slave only supports read.
But if the master crash,
slave will take over
and becomes a master.
The replication between
these two instances
are done by semi-synchronous
replication,
in the sense that each and
every writes on that master
has to be durably committed
on the relay log of the slave,
before the master can consider
that transaction successful.
That part somehow guarantees
durability, in the sense
that a transaction is
persisted on both copies on two
different hosts.
In this particular example,
as you can see there,
even persisting in
two different zones.
So however, the
semi part comes in.
When the slave picks up
this transaction window,
applies that
particular transaction
to the database of the slave,
it does that asynchronously
in the background.
And generally, it
only has one thread
that's picking up those
transactions from the relay log
and applies to the database.
It has only one
thread in MySQL 5.6.
It has an option to enable
multiple sites in MySQL 5.7.
And we haven't enabled
that yet because there
have been some concerns about
reliability and data integrity
issues.
So bottom line, if the incoming
write rate to the master
exceeds the capabilities
of the slave,
that single thread on slave
can apply this transaction,
then you have replication lag.
Those transactions will
be saved in the relay log.
They are safe, but the slave
is lagging behind the master.
So let's take a look
at the replication lag,
and why it matters.
Why?
Because when the
failover happened,
the slave has to apply all those
transactions in the relay log
onto its database, before
it can open up for business.
And, remember in this
high HA architecture,
the slave is actually
hot and online.
If you don't have
any replication lag,
then the slave should just be
able to take over and flip over
really fast.
Now, this connects back to
the concept called RTO, which
is Recovery Time Objective.
So every serious production
use of my MySQL, the business
have a need to support a
particular recovery time
objective.
In this case that
if the master dies,
the slave has to be up and
running within x seconds.
That's your recovery
time objective.
And so it's therefore
important that you
need to be able to monitor and
control your replication lag
if you want to make sure that
your system can fit and meet
your RTO.
One way to do it is to throttle
your application's write read.
And there is a way to do it.
It's probably a harder way is to
partition and shatter database
and have a different instance.
So let's take a look
at how do you monitor
in the see replication lag?
So this, I showed
an example here,
which is the SQL command you
can run on the slave side.
And basically, on
the slave side,
MySQL maintains a
status variable called
Seconds_Behind_Master, so you
can do a show slave status
and then grab for
Seconds_Behind_Master.
And so replication lag is
measured in seconds, not
in milliseconds, not in
hours, but in seconds.
And so here, the
Seconds_Behind_Master
is 1,586 seconds.
That means the slave
is still applying
the transaction that has
happened on the master 1,500
seconds ago.
So it's a pretty bad situation.
Well, bad or good,
depending on your RTO.
So here's another view
of the replication lag.
Let's see how--
The chart is a little bit
blurry on those lines,
but I think you can still see
the numbers and the lines.
So this is a sysbench
run, sysbench OLTP
run on MySQL 5.6 instance.
And the way we run
this experiment is we
increment a test load--
doubled.
We doubled a test load
each step of the way.
Each step here runs
for 20 minutes.
So here, you can see on the
x-axis, as a test thread count,
we run from 1, 2, 4, 8,
all the way to 256 threads.
On the y-axis, is
basically the number,
the slave reported
seconds behind master.
So you can see on this
graph, when you run the test,
it ranges from 1 to
8 threads, we are OK.
We pretty much don't
have any replication lag,
it's pretty much close to 0.
Now, at 6 test thread count,
the incoming write rates
start to exceed the
rate the slave can apply
those transactions,
and you start
to have non-zero replication
lag, and all the way to 256
so that you have a couple
of thousand seconds behind.
One key thing to remember
here, though, on this chart,
is that are you OK to
run at 16 thread count?
Probably not.
Because at that level,
your incoming write rate
is already exceeding,
exceeded your slave--
there's a rate slave can
apply those transaction.
In the sense that if you
keep running on this one,
this line is going to keep
increasing, keep increasing.
So keeping that's an
example of replication lag.
And then next slide, I'm going
to talk about how do we monitor
and to control them?
How do we moderate?
So this one shows
the relationship
between replication
lag and the transaction
and a raw performance.
So previous slides
showed examples
of replication lag,
this one brings the TPS
into the picture.
So the way to read
this picture is
x-axis, again, is a test load.
This is, again,
sysbench OLTP run,
and each step runs
for about 20 minutes.
And we run from one thread
to all the way to 256 thread.
On this chart there are
lines and there is columns.
Columns are for replication lag.
And its on the write
axis, right y-axis.
And these are in seconds.
And then so lines are for
TPS, transaction per second.
These are for on
the left y-axis.
So and also, you can note
there are two lines here.
One is the red, which is
from a non-replicated test.
And then the green one
is for a replicate test.
And one interesting
thing to note
is that because we're using
semi-synchronous replication,
the performance gap between non-
replicate and the replicated,
isn't that big.
Because if we are going through
the completely synchronous
replication, especially
if you're across zone,
you would expect to see much
larger gap on these two lines.
But because we are using
semi-synchronous replication,
the performance hit
from non-replicated one
isn't that much big.
However, the price
we are paying here
is the replication lag here.
So the way it can read the
chart is for this 32 test thread
count, we are able to
achieve about 200 TPS.
And those are the p50 TPS.
But the replication lag, we
can see at the end of this 20
minutes that is 467 seconds.
So what does that mean?
How does that help you on this?
Let's look at the next slide.
So on this slide, it's the same
picture as the previous one.
I marked two
distinct TPS ranges.
The first one is what I
call a sustained TPS range.
So is the sustained TPS range,
it ranges from 0 to 200,
and then you can run
from one test column--
1 test thread to 8 test thread.
In this range, your replication
lag is virtually zero.
So you can run your application
at this TPS for a very, very
long time without
ever needing to worry
about violating your RTO.
However, when you start
to exceed this range,
then you will start to
accrue your replication lag.
This is what we call a peek TPS.
So from time to time,
your application
would like to burst,
would like to exceed
the standard TPS range.
That's what the TPS--
peak TPS is.
So the way you want to
model your application
is that you would
run your workload,
and you create a charge
similar to this one.
And then you also
consider how long you
would allow that first to go.
And then you can see
if the replication
lag at the end of your
burst is below your RTO.
For example, if you're RTO
is 500, in this case, then
that means your peak TPS
can be as high as 200
for up to 20 minutes.
So on the lower right
corner of the slide,
you can see a
little formula here
is that the peak TPS times
the duration you want
to burst your TPS to, times
your estimated replication lag
growth rate, should be
controlled under your RTO.
So why do we do this?
How does this thing help you?
The most important
information this can give you
is to help you do
capacity planning.
So imagine you have
your application.
Your application has some
kind of write workload.
You can run this write
workload, varying its load,
and then collect replication
lag and the TPS numbers.
And then you can also
get a good estimate
of how much burst you want to
give to the application for how
long, during our business day.
Or during the previous runs.
So when you find
all this information
that you can plan
properly, first, you
can consider a threat
to your application
to make sure that
when it bursts,
it doesn't burst above
certain TPS level.
Second, if you really,
really want that many TPS,
then you also want
to stick to your RTO.
Then the next natural
choice is probably
to shatter and
partition your database,
and have another one to serve
and divide your write traffic.
So OK.
That is the section for the
availability and performance.
So the next section, I'm going
to go over some of the Cloud
SQL specific InnoDB tuning
we have done, to make sure
MySQL works better
on the GC platform.
So for Cloud SQL, we have
tried to tune various InnoDB
parameters, because InnoDB is--
MySQL, is a very established
and a mature product.
And it was designed for
bare medal hardware,
and later was also
the default set
of the InnoDB parameters,
what made in such a way
that the database can run safely
on all sorts of platforms.
So, in order to make
in InnoDB and MySQL
work best for GCE, which
as a cloud environment,
has its unique
characteristics, for example,
for Persistent Disk, actually
its write performance
and write latency is
better than reads.
And also, was a new persistent
disk IOPS and the bandwidth
great.
And actually, read has
more bandwidth than writes
on some of the machine types.
So there are all kinds of
clouds unique and properties
that makes it almost required
to tune the InnoDB in a way
that it could work best on
the Google Cloud platform.
So but I would like to start
with one quick note here,
is all tunings and
the settings described
here are subject to change.
So view this section as more
like for your information,
for your reference, in
case it also helps you.
If you want to, you can
run your own MySQL instance
on our GCE platform.
We are constantly
working on this,
and we will constantly
be making improvements
based on new information and
new developments happening
on the underlying
operating system.
So we will change those
parameters as we see fit,
and sometimes we may even decide
to revert when some of those
to default if new
information warrants such.
So keep that in mind.
And I don't think
there's any reason
to take a hard dependency
on these particular values.
So let's start
with the first one.
InnoDB [INAUDIBLE], which
is one almost everyone
tunes when they write an
InnoDB on their hardware.
So it's critical for
performance for reads mostly,
and maybe also for writes.
So it needs to be set according
to the available RAM on the VM.
And standard
recommendation is about 80%
of the total RAM of the VM.
So what we set it to is
here, the wall of text.
There's many text here, but
just remember two numbers--
92% and 80%.
So we take 92% of the total
amount of RAM of the VM,
and assign, give it to MySQL.
And then we take 80% of
the MySQL's RAM to InnoDB
buffer pool.
Now there are a bunch
of caveats here,
because on smaller VMs for
for m1-standard-4 and below,
and even for my
core and the small.
Those little VMs, we have
to tune down those numbers
to make sure they can run
safely and are reliable,
they don't crash.
So for us, for those who are
interested in doing performance
work, if the data
m1-standard-8 and above,
then these two
numbers will apply.
And we actually
highly recommend you
guys to run 16 core or above for
performance, heavy performance
intense workload.
It's not an upsell.
And it's really an
honest suggestion
for many, many reasons.
For example, just
recently Persistent Disk
announced higher IOPS and
the bandwidth offering.
And the number of cores
actually played a role
on the underlying disk
capability you can get.
Not just the sites.
For six 16 core machines
so you can get 25,000 IOPS.
And 480 megabytes reads
and 240 megabytes writes.
So those are not available
in lower core machines,
even if you buy at
very, very large disk.
So 16 core and above,
we highly recommend
for performance workload.
Now, next set of
parameters, which is buffer
pool initialization.
We enable buffer pool
persistence at shutdown
and the buffer pool
preload at startup.
So this allows us to
pre-warm the cache
and to reduce
performance variability
in between across DB reboots.
Pre-warm cache is better
than randomly warming them up
during your production workload.
Next one.
Redo log size.
So this is the most
important parameter.
I think one of the most
important parameters
for write heavy workload.
Default is 48 megabytes,
which is really too small.
512 megabytes is what
we set, and we set it
to two log files, each
of which 512 megabytes.
So in total, you get 1
gigabyte worth of redo logs.
So it helps absolve
incoming write spikes.
I would talk a lot more
about what I mean here
by sync flash state.
So next one is networking.
Networking here always
tuned to two settings.
One is to max_allowed_packet to
32 megabytes from 4 megabyte,
and the other one
is max_connections.
So max_connections to 4,000.
So max_allowed_packet
allows your kind
to sending large
queries, in case
you want to insert
a big BLOB column.
Or you have very long
strings in your query
that would be supported.
So max_connections
is self-explanatory.
So InnoDB metrics monitoring.
So there is a set of InnoDB
metrics in the information
schema table.
Those are actually
pretty useful.
The default is
actually not enabled.
So we enabled all
type of those metrics
in that particular table.
Now there's a difference between
that table and a performance
schema.
Performance schema
is pretty heavy,
and comes with not
so ideal overhead.
But for this particular table,
the overhead is trivial,
and the information it
provides is valuable.
So we turn it on,
and it turns out
to be very useful for our
investigation and debugging
purpose.
OK.
So for the next
set of slides, I'm
going to talk a little bit
about dirty page flushes.
So for InnoDB tuning,
for you to tune writes,
to tune dirty page flush
and to make it properly,
and to make it
adjusted and adapt
to your incoming write row,
is really, really important.
So let's first start with
a little bit of overview
of what dirty page is.
And it has to start with the
way how InnoDB implement writes.
A write has to happen in two
places concurrently in InnoDB.
First, it has to be
persistent in the redo log.
Second, the write will be made
into an in-memory data page,
which is in the buffer pool.
And once the writes is
written in the data page,
it's called a dirty page.
And then at the
background, InnoDB
has a mechanism called
Adaptive Flushing, that
will appear [INAUDIBLE]
flush those dirty pages
into the on-disk data file.
Only after the 30 pages are
flushed to the disk file,
to the data file, then the
content in the redo log
can be reclaimed.
And the space in the redo
log can be three to four
subsequent writes.
So that's the way
InnoDB handles writes.
Here are the two
settings we tuned
to make the flush a little
bit faster and more capable.
One is called
innodb_flush_method,
we change that to O_DIRECT.
Which makes the InnoDB to open
the data file in O_DIRECT mode,
so each and every write
will hit the disk directly
without depending on
the subsequent fsync.
So it makes using
fsync really fast.
The second one is
innodb_io_capacity.
The default is only 200.
So this is a number that feeds
into the Adaptive Flushing
algorithm, and tells it
how many dirty pages it can
flush per iteration.
There are many, many
other parameters,
but this one is one of
the most important ones.
So it has to tie into
the underlying IO
capacity of the block device.
And our persistent
disk, we can support up
to 15,000, 20,000 IOPS.
And so if we change
that to 5,000,
it turns out to be
pretty well for us.
So the next set of
parameters that we tuned,
which is currently
for MySQL 5.7 only,
and it's still in the
process of being rolled out
to production, which will
be available everywhere
probably in a few weeks.
Those are really, really for
the tuning for a problem called
sync flush point.
Remember, I just
described how InnoDB
does writes to the redo
log, and to the dirty page,
and then delivery gets flushed.
Once it's flushed, the redo
log space gets reclaimed.
Now think about this.
If the income incoming
write rate far
exceeded the rate InnoDB
can flush dirty page,
then your redo
log space is going
to grow, grow, grow to a point.
Usually it's about
80% of your limit.
Then InnoDB gets
into a panic mode.
So-called panic mode
is called sync flush.
It means that it will not
accept your next write until it
can find the oldest dirty
page, flush it to the disk,
flush it to the
data file, reclaim
some space from
the redo log, then
they will accept
your new writes.
So from your application level,
you will see on your TPS chart,
this forms something called
a stop-and-go pattern.
Your stop, your TPS will drop.
And then you could go
back up because the redo
logs has more space.
And then you will see a huge
fluctuation of your TPS.
It will hurt your
capacity planning,
it will hurt your
front and application
because it doesn't know how to
set timeout when this happens.
And things will just randomly
time out and will fail.
So here is a set
of four settings
we tuned to help and
tackle this problem.
And they attacked this
problem from different angles.
For first one, makes
the flush more smart.
It always tried to
flash a contiguous
region of 1 megabyte
of data rather than
a bunch of random writes.
The second one makes a flush
do more work for iteration.
It was scan all pages
in the [INAUDIBLE] tree.
And the third one makes
the flush respond faster
to the incoming load.
And the fourth one increases
the parallelism of the flush.
So here's sync flush
problem [INAUDIBLE]
just described earlier.
It was [AUDIO OUT] still.
This is a sysbench step
load function each.
Step is 2x the load
of the previous one.
And what's plotted
here on the y-axis
is the flush lag in bytes.
So remember, we have 1
gigabyte was of redo log space,
80% is about 800 megabytes.
Here is about 800 megabytes.
So as you can see,
when we run the test
at 128 threads of
sysbench, it quickly--
the flush lag, it
quickly hits the ceiling,
hits the point where InnoDB
gets into the sync flush state.
And InnoDB start the
stop-and-go mode,
and you cannot go
higher anymore.
So if you-- I can show you the
TPS chart in just two slides.
The TPS looks horrible.
And it will just up
and down, up and down.
So after the tune in, you
see that's the after picture
that we successfully
suppressed the growth
rate of the flush lag.
That at 128 thread
and 250 thread,
it is kept away from
the sync flush state.
But at 256, it still hits
a red line occasionally,
and there's still
more turning to do.
So here's an end effect
of the tuned versus
untuned at 128 threads.
So if you remember the previous
sync flush and the flush lag
chart at 128 threads,
shortly after test start,
we hit the sync flush
state, and then you
can see this is a TPS chart.
It went as low as 400, and
then it goes back up to 2400.
And then goes up and
down and up and down.
So [INAUDIBLE], the
tuning that was applied,
at least it gives you a
very-- a pretty stable
lower bound of 1,200 to 1,200.
You know, upper bound
it still shoots up,
and it gets-- you can still
get better performance,
but the key point here is that
as a predictable and reliable
lower bound of the performance.
Now with that, I'm going
to turn the mic back
to Brett to talk
about next steps.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Thank
you much, Stanley.
I think all of you-- we
had a number of developers
raise their hand at the
beginning of the presentation.
Some DBAs and even
more reluctant DBAs.
And I think the takeaway for
me from Stanley's InnoDB tuning
work, is that we've gone from
a place where by default MySQL,
on Compute Engine or on GCP
generally, shows pretty wide
variability in performance.
You see that on the right
hand portion of the graph.
And then we move
to the left, where
we have a much more consistent
performance experience.
I think if you're a
developer, or certainly a DBA,
unwinding variability
in performance
is not an easy problem.
And the work that Stanley's
done has gone a long way
to help us there.
For those of you using
Cloud SQL, what you've
seen from Stanley today is
in your database instance,
and we'll continue to optimize
a number of settings relevant,
we think, to MySQL
on Google Cloud,
and more specifically
in Cloud SQL.
For folks who are
self-managing, who
are thinking about running
a database on Compute Engine
or are already doing
so, as I mentioned,
we have the InnoDB metrics
or the InnoDB metrics
that Stanley was showing,
listed online at GitHub Gist.
So you can take a
look at this URL.
We'll continue to update
that document online
as we make further
progress with our tuning.
Stanley and I joke that
we're on an endless mission
here to performance
tune databases on GCP.
And hopefully you'll see
us and share this kind
of information going forward.
We plan to, in that we want
to make Cloud SQL very open
and build it on products
that you, yourself, can
use in Google Cloud.
So that you have a real
choice between self-managing
and a managed database service.
A couple of points
to wrap up on.
Scaling Cloud SQL.
Think back to the
infrastructure scaling up.
CPU and in-memory,
I think, is very
straightforward and intuitive.
Remember that scaling IOPS
means number of CPU cores
and capacity of storage.
Whether or not you're
using Cloud SQL,
you can use our create
form to calculate what kind
of expected performance
levels you'll
get based on number
of cores and size
of your persistent
disk storage device.
Look forward, as always, to
future announcements, faster
storage, larger instance types.
I don't think we're
quite done just yet.
When we talk about optimizing
performance and availability,
some key points to remember.
So Cloud SQL uses MySQL's
semi-synchronous replication
technology for
high availability.
What this means is
consider your workload,
and how it might
influence the replication
lag that Stanley talked about
where replication lag can
affect your failover time.
It can affect your availability.
You will not lose
data, or the goal
of semi-synchronous replication
is to ensure data durability
across zones.
But there is that
RTO implication
that Stanley pointed out.
The gist here for you, is if
you have a very bursty workload,
you are pretty
unconstrained even when
using semi-synchronous
replication.
Stanley showed you the two
lines, a MySQL database
instance without replication,
which is essentially as
fast as MySQL can go.
It's just doing
its work locally.
Versus a replication
pair, a master instance
with a failover replica.
And the lines tracked
pretty closely.
What that means is
for a bursty workload,
you're going to get
a lot of performance
out of your replication pair.
And you'll give
your replication--
your failover replica,
rather, some time
to catch up if it gets
behind the master.
If instead your workload is
not bursty, if it is consistent
and you were driving inserts and
updates on a consistent basis,
take a look at what
Stanley showed with respect
to a sustainable TPS.
If you start to get
a replica behind,
and you continue to
write inserts, updates,
the replica can go further
and further behind,
and you may have to throttle
from the application side.
I think those were the
two takeaways, in my mind,
from those charts.
The numbers will surely
change in the future.
Stanley mentioned we
showed TPS on the y-axis.
I'm sure the numbers
will change over time,
but the general implications
of semi-synchronous replication
and MySQL won't
change nearly as fast.
So hopefully you're
familiar with those now.
Again, visit our
GitHub Gist page
for all of the InnoDB
tuning parameters.
That way, if you are
self-managing on GCP,
you can get started
more quickly.
A few presentation pics for you.
We are on day three
of the conference.
I'm sure all of you are feeling
at least a touch of fatigue
at this point.
That said, we've got more
sessions this afternoon.
Here are three that
grabbed my attention
and grabbed Stanley's attention.
10 common causes of downtime
and how to avoid them.
That's 8302.
Building high
performance microservices
with Kubernetes, and some really
cool stuff in Go and gRPC.
And lastly, a talk focusing on
Bigtable, our NoSQL product.
And this one is focusing on
serving personalized content.
So serving content to millions
of users at really low latency.
With that, I want
to remind everyone
you can get started not just
with Cloud SQL for MySQL,
but now Cloud SQL for
PostgreSQL as well, as of today.
And on behalf of Stanley,
I want to thank you
all for spending a bit of
your afternoon with us.